- This is gonna be tough cuz
I do not understand American
standards of beauty.
(low-key music)
- According to a recent study,
what percentage from each gender
prefer the their partners
to have slender bodies?
- Slender bodies is
such a subjective term.
What is slender?
- Okay, so definitely more
men than women, I believe.
- I'm gonna say 58% men, 68% women.
(buzzer)
- Whatever, everybody has
their own thing, I guess.
I like chubby guys anyway, so.
- Among the list, what physical features
on the male body is
considered the least important
in America?
- We all know it's not the jawline
because dear God, if
you have a good jawline,
hold me back.
- It's between shoulders
and jawline for me.
I'm gonna say jawline.
(ding)
Woo!
Finally one thing right.
- Only 10% of American women actually have
the body type typically associated with
ideal women body size slash
shape in advertisements.
- I would say true.
10%, yeah.
- I would say less than that.
Because those women are Photoshopped,
and so how are you supposed to achieve
a Photoshopped body?
So, I'm gonna go with false.
(ding)
- We are trained since
little girls to like
idolize this one shape that only 5%
of women in America have.
- In a survey by AARP,
men and women scored
their physical appearance
a seven point one on average
on a zero to 10 point scale.
- I think we see ourselves
as more attractive
so 7.1 seems about right.
- Oh, I don't know.
It could be like a 6.4.
- I say false.
I feel like people are always undervaluing
their personal looks.
(ding)
- I got it right, 6.4, legitimately?
- I think seven is a good
number to give yourself.
This is bull.
- I just know coming
from my own insecurities,
I view myself a lot less
than I probably should.
And I think that most people do.
It's just really sad to
see that data behind it.
- These patterns of how we
like judge our attractiveness
are so ingrained in who we are,
and it's just so hard to let go of them.
- If you really wanted
to find what beauty is,
I think beauty, it's about who
you are as a person inside.
Don't let people tell you
that you're not important.
You define yourself,
and you let yourself be that to the world.